pounding waterfalls grueling hikes
leaping over fire these are the trials
of the yamabushi some of the toughest
monks in Japan in Yamagata prefecture
Japan the three mountains of dae-hwa are
considered a sacred pilgrimage site for
spiritual group known as the Yamabushi
Hajime OTA is a priest who has obtained
the highest level of training for a
yamabushi TV Madonna has a no Toki knee
so no Yama position has emeritus
disclaimer column or don't you call a
minor desk little more Sichuan a typical
Tamaki denied a scalable provision so
that position was so that second
internet connection online the practices
of the Yamaguchi involved intense
self-discipline in order to obtain a
form of spiritual enlightenment and
today mr. Otis shares the Yamaguchi
training with people from all over the
country cool
Konohamaru come on you have been cooking
in controversial take a joke with the
skismo
kuleana how come you cut in half so
sinner well nobody ever got a singer
what the net that extent has emitted
scrap Oh each other contacts just get
them all our holidays honor TVC question
at all she's got a billionaire because
someone you know hadn't be a more
quadratic donor potassium contains curry
endlessly so se llaman catalytics dinner
honest collector color than equal to
Tokyo dystonia
can you cut some super token to dinner
[Music]
yamaoka chemo takes Denair something
you're talking Latta mr. Matsumoto
proton deletion hims discolor Mayo
katana it tells Twitter Lanikai Studs
Terkel I tell us a sign amigo singer
what the mo kinetic the talking he know
we're a little Eastern we had together
to me desk little more she knows I kinda
hate America at Attica Rock Arizona
report you see the CEO motivated
container it's in everydays the
coca-cola return until the citizen yeah
paraquad owaranai mahou in autonomic
automatic you Delta to me must flow for
sacred silver you see your scallop or
condi ammonia ammonia high tenor singer
second et la cucina zhou dongyu kana de
cervantes a oh no no no Elena tamiana
you know a lotta mitochondria cell
renewal you know we said to me
[Music]